spokesperson for the former prime
minister has said that he was invited to
Ukraine by president zielinski that his
visit was at the invitation of the
Ukrainian presidency and that his
message is that Ukraine will win and
Putin must fail
um and essentially it's just to
demonstrate solidarity
um with the people
um of Ukraine
um now uh the quotes that we've been
given is Boris Johnson saying that it's
a privilege to visit Ukraine at the
invitation of President zelenski the
suffering of the people of Ukraine has
gone on for too long and the only way to
end this war is for Ukraine um to win
now we were told that or understood that
after leaving number 10 Mr Johnson
wanted to make this section of foreign
policy of Ukraine really one of his
interests I think it's probably viewed
as one of the high points of his time in
Downing Street essentially being heavily
involved and at the front of the western
response to the Russian invasion of
Ukraine so not necessarily a surprise
that he's over there I think in terms of
domestic politics though it will maybe
be seen as Boris Johnson attempting to
muscle in on this pretty crucial part of
foreign policy that of course now Falls
to Rishi soon act to play a big part in
Robin Westminster thank you